[Music]
okay it's time for uh jk detective uh
agency all right let's do this all right
let's go got my detective hat on let's
go ready
so a georgia woman gets arrested right
they put her in the police car in the
back okay
close the door
start driving off to uh the police
station
somehow
she falls out of the car and dies
because they didn't lock the door but
it's a child lock you you don't even
have to do it yourself when you close
the door it always locks from the inside
she fell out of the car she somehow fell
out there's a sinkhole in the car
so
they don't they don't know how this
could possibly happen yet but of course
foul play is like what everyone's kind
of going towards they think because
while it was driving the cop pulled the
handlebar from the other side i mean the
door and then she fell out
that would be really [ __ ] up yeah the
car the door didn't close all the way
and the cop didn't do the
damage
[Music]
close the door all the way with his head
yeah yeah yeah forgot to do that that's
procedure you know you know what i'm
saying yeah and so it's on my police
manual yeah you gotta [ __ ] you gotta
hit that so the funny thing is as like
as many weird theories as we can think
of the department's probably thinking of
just as many like weird ones too yeah
because
wait a second wait a second
so a lot of these police cars have
cameras in them right that's active
recording voice and stuff like that
couldn't they just get the recording oh
but usually in these situations they
malfunction
oh yeah the body counts are off somehow
they always yeah
see that's why the police department
needs more money because they need to
recharge their batteries
buy more cameras they need more e-card
a bigger sd card they're only using like
13 gig cards i feel like the cops were
probably doing something illegal like
for example maybe she was a hooker or
whatever and then they were using her
services and then they arrested her and
then now that was them trying to kill
her or something in a legal way
but that's [ __ ] up see i don't
understand killing hookers you know it's
like you should be giving them
more like they just they just made you
[ __ ] come so like after that it's
like
it's like do you kill santa after he
gives you a present no you wouldn't
whatever
so why do people keep killing hookers
yeah that's not nice isn't that nice
yeah and what kind of cop car was this
was it a rose voice like like suicide
doors the doors opening
this way because the door opening
regular like with the car driving it
would just close on its own so she would
kind of have to force her way out of it
unless it was suicide it was like the
lambo cops you know oh yeah
okay yeah
yeah you do buy cops so here's um here's
an like interesting segue into the whole
988 thing remember how you called 988
now when you're having like a mental
health crisis you don't call 9-1-1 oh i
don't know that not 9-1-1 it's 9-8-8
right
but right now is a separate thing but
right now 98's being criticized for kind
of still having the same like shitty
response where you get cops anyway of
course most of the time so um because
you're having a breakdown what do they
want they want a counsellor to be go
come up there yeah really yeah i mean
it's it's hard to do but that's that's
everybody's kind of like where sirens
sound like
helping helping help no you know what it
is it's it's the [ __ ]
thing
and it's like an ice cream you know
because everybody feels happy parlor
music i think you're not going crazy yet
now you are hearing this thing approach
some old-timey music so um
she was um she was just having a mental
health crisis so her her own family
called uh they called the police
um start with that at the top bro
we already went in we're already winning
i just like that one we have to test out
all theories you guys yeah all right
this is what being a detective is about
so a woman fell out of the car well i
don't think we should be killing hookers
that jump it's like
i didn't see that going what oh
potentially we have to ask that
so yeah she apparently has they've this
has happened two times before but the
other previous two times the right
things were done were like you know
somebody came and calmed her down and
they did all the things that uh i guess
every person having a mental health
crisis that should be done that way
right but the third time was straight up
cops and they put her in the car and
then this um officer that was driving
told the family that
um that woman kicked the door open and
jumped out of the car
what because i've seen videos of of
people being on like pcp and then they
like
kick the door and then run away
interesting because they said that she's
been trying to cope with her mental
health by using illegal drugs so maybe
she was on something
oh interesting she was on some [ __ ] for
sure so the hooker thing is completely
out
off the table okay so we're done with
that off the table let's run make sure
we're just going to sorry
are we going to believe her i always
thought it was really weird how like if
if someone's like um on like oh [ __ ]
they're danger to themselves suicide
right so then like they're like i'm a
[ __ ] off myself right and the cop
just comes up they'll be like drop that
and it's like
you're just gonna kill the person that's
trying to kill themselves yes stupid
[ __ ] so that was something like whenever
whenever i was a correctional officer i
worked uh i actually had a i stopped i
prevented somebody from hanging them you
say you were a correctionalist yes i was
i worked at i worked at a prison you
know i was a ceo i was a ceo when i was
18 years old wow you were a ceo at 18.
yes yes
how did you even get them to listen to
you bro
yeah yo so all you need is a a high
school diploma and then they pass the
academy and you're they throw you into
prisons in texas yeah
how long was the academy for uh like six
weeks
and it's like one of those you have to
live there or uh
six weeks
yeah that's a pretty robust training
program
i mean yeah that's all that's all it was
yo um you know a lot of i mean a lot of
uh you know what is it handbook
paperwork assignments stuff with that
and then there's the the like uh the pt
stuff right but i mean even that kind of
stuff they teach you like when an inmate
goes like this and squares up to you do
not fight or like do they teach you your
strongest weapon is your pin
that's what they teach you no because
you take their you take their id and you
write them up that's what they teach
when they have a knife to your [ __ ]
chest
i'll write you up for this yeah
the pen is mightier than the sword so
the so the rule is with the with the
what because you also have gas so it's
the mace right so so that's so that's
your great weapon right and so but uh
if if an inmate is uh is in the process
of uh attempting to hang themselves it's
um our job to prevent that and gas them
you know get them from yeah but if
they're already hanging like imagine
like if you if you you're dashing them
while they're in the water
it's like what you're saying which is
just now yeah
and so that was the moment like
literally it was count time and we have
to uh every every three hours we're
counting the inmates and this inmate i'm
passing that counted them but i saw him
like taking his sheets and you know
doing this with them right and and i was
like i just i saw that but i was like
okay i'm just going and i was in my head
about that like yo what's he doing he
just likes that wrinkled look yeah yeah
yeah he's about to go back
he's like yeah he's just gonna he's just
trying to pop his celery just trying to
play with it rough housing but i'm but
i'm in the i'm in the psych ward so
they're they're in the they're these
inmates are in their cells by themselves
they're also they need pills because
they're a little off in their head you
know and so and so apparently you heard
voices that's what you hear later later
on about it but um he uh he was tying it
to the top of the the bars or whatever
and so
whenever i got back to um
like back from you know to go to my desk
now he's like wrapping it around his
neck oh my god and that's where i was
like yo lal hey hey hey and you're 18.
yeah yeah yeah yeah and literally like i
like a split decision like it was just
like real quick because i was like we
just i was just
like taught this in the academy like
what to like these examples that they
were showing these videos and these
inmates like we watched these videos of
these people doing this stuff and so i'm
literally watching exactly what i was
just taught and i was like oh snap
you're training kick yeah this is it
yeah okay so and so i have to i have to
like warn him before i guess them the
other rule is you have to warn them
because they can also sue this is the
whole thing too inmates can sue cos and
it's the whole thing and so i'm like hey
man take that off your neck and and he's
like he's like no he's all like it's
it's
you know adrenaline and everything's
like i'm doing it and it's also i'm like
take that off you're not my i'm about to
guess you and and he's just like he's
like no and i just took it i remember
like that was my first time even using
my gas is it like a spray is it a spray
yeah just so like a what if it was the
wrong way you just hit your [ __ ] eye
yeah
so i just remember like i like i i will
like you're like oh [ __ ] i feel bad for
this
[Laughter]
i went like this because i was like i
didn't know what it was gonna feel like
i just sprayed it i was going like this
i think he's also done this before
because he had his little fan that he
got from commissary and it was blowing
towards me oh so he already he already
set all this up oh no
yeah to like get out of his cell and get
some proper care to just kind of be get
his yes this was all just to [ __ ] with
me right
whoa and so i'm doing this it's spraying
back towards me of course i'm still
getting on him but he's all just [ __ ]
like i'm choking up trouble chugging the
inmates are trolling of course you choke
him up you're about to be choking if you
put this on you like they're just
talking
they were talking mad [ __ ] yo yeah yo
and then even when even like so whenever
the sergeants come i'm like calling on
the radio the sergeants come running out
there they're they're bringing me
they're like cleaning me off and stuff
and like i'm looking we still have to do
procedures before we get an inmate out
of their cell we have to check their
hands check their hair check their in
the inside their gums strip search
because
they could they could have a weapon like
they're just trying to like
hit an inmate or hit a uh you know what
i'm saying so this [ __ ] is
choking coughing all of a sudden he's
like
he's doing all this [ __ ] you gotta check
him while he's all that [ __ ] bro strip
search too both of you guys are just
[ __ ] up yeah yeah
yeah bro it was a whole [ __ ] show when i
brought him out um he's like cupped and
like taking them to the the the nurses
whatever but those inmates were just
like damn damn boss you painted them
boss you painted that boy balls he
painted a pen yeah yeah but i remember
that whole did you unload the whole cat
on them that was even a thing too like
so whenever you use a gas uh uh um
whenever you use it you have to dispose
it no matter if it's one use yeah it's
one use and so uh the the the ceos they
say like they are the lieutenants
they're like you're gonna use it you
might as well use all of it because we
ain't gonna be able to use it just like
waste it whatever man they want to go
weigh it whenever they were going about
our paperwork and all these things
you know i pretty much just used
whoa
you basically cool watered him that's
the entire time i'm sitting here
thinking like i went [ __ ] [ __ ] gas
this whole thing yo i just use like a
little bit
oh my god
like me too
it must be strong a little bit more it
must be stronger he was overreacting it
was uh it was straight it must have been
really strong in like an older like can
cause you know you know you rarely use
your mates so the things just sit there
just [ __ ] you know so i guess it'll
just like age like wine or something
yeah yeah i didn't use a lot but i
remember that procedure like lieutenant
like talking about like what exactly
happened because the paperwork is so
important and it was seen for senior
year yeah yeah because he was just like
did you say
i'm take that off your neck or i'm gonna
have to guess you like all this i'm like
i said all of that you don't see it 18.
yeah you're so nice dude what a [ __ ]
first job huh
[Music]